from their bases in Taiwan fighter jets
take to the skies as part of an exercise
in Readiness for warplanes coming from
mainland China incursions by China's Air
Force doubled in 2022 with Beijing
determined to unite with what it regards
as a renegade Breakaway province for
taiwan's president saying when these
threats are a reminder of why her
government is keeping its distance from
the mainland as she restated in her
Lunar New Year message
the military is steadfast in holding
their posts defending our national
security and our common Homeland with
all their might
her vice president and the man widely
expected to succeed her when Taiwan
elects a new president in a year's time
holds similarly defiant views
facing the threat from China in the
future our new mission is to protect
Taiwan promote democracy peace and
prosperity in that Quest Taiwan can
count on the might of its Ally the
United States a strike group led by the
aircraft carrier Nimitz is the latest
deployment to the disputed Waters of the
South and East China seas and sailing
through the sensitive Taiwan Strait
which China regards as a highly
provocative act taiwan's increasing
geopolitical importance underpinned by
its Global high-tech business clout has
raised the stakes in this potential
Flashpoint China's president Xi Jinping
having secured an unprecedented
extension to his time in office seems to
have made unification with Taiwan his
legacy Mission
both sides of the Taiwan Strait belong
to One China which is a fact with clear
historical evidence and legal basis
Taiwan has never been a state nor will
it become one taiwan's very existence as
a thriving Democratic de facto state is
an affront that China struggles to live
with Rob McBride Al Jazeera